j'accueille maintenant fatouma diarra
sidibé amina sonia rolland et stomy
bugzy
tout un bon soir vous avez 20 ans dont
dix sept ans passés dans des taudis
vous avez survécu à l'incendié du
boulevard vincent auriol à paris dans le
xiiie dans la nuit du 25 au 26 août mais
vous avez perdu votre fille de trois ans
et vos sept frères et soeurs votre père
est toujours hospitalisé et il ne sait
pas que les petits sont morts
amina sidibé vous êtes chargé du
problème des femmes au sein du haut
conseil des maliens de france
sonia on ne vous présente pas et vous
non plus tôt me mais merci d'être là
pour les pour les soutenir voilà alors
depuis le mois d'avril les incendies
d'immeubles insalubres se multiplient à
paris le 15 avril 24 morts dont 11
enfants
dans un hôtel qui s'appelait paris opéra
le 26 août 17 morts dont 14 enfants
boulevard vincent auriol le 29 août sept
morts dont quatre enfants rue du roi
doré la france compte aujourd'hui trois
millions de mal logés
mais au delà des statistiques
je voudrais qu'on regarde la réalité en
face parce que c'est notre réalité et
nous en sommes tous responsables
fatou bonsoir donc votre père est venu
en france en
1978 pour faire vivre sa famille au mali
oui il n'avait pas le choix ils étaient
obligés de venir oui parce qu'il était
fils unique
famille votre mère et les deux aînés
dont vous l'avait rejoint en 1988
et en 1991 vous êtes tous retrouvé sous
des bâches en plastique sur le chantier
du quai de la gare pendant quatre mois
vous vous aviez six ans
quels souvenirs vous gardez de ce
chantier du quai de la gare
de la boue
et plus vert il y avait beaucoup de boue
des fois il y avait des fuites dans des
tentes quand on dormait on était à
plusieurs
noms cités avec mon frère mon jeune
frère dans le même lit d'un litige une
place quoi
alors ensuite emmaüs a trouvé cet
immeuble boulevard vincent auriol
qui était en très mauvais état mais pour
vous c'était mieux que dormir dehors oui
mais c'était quand il est rentré c'était
pour six mois quoi
duré qu'un mois et vous y seriez encore
si lui même n'avait pas volé
le 26 avril après l'incendié de l'hôtel
paris opéra une équipe de france 2 est
venue filmer
boulevard vincent auriol vous avez
raconté à l'époque les morsures des rats
sur les enfants et la peur du feu que
vous aviez et madame cissé qui avait
témoigné dans ce reportage est morte
ainsi que beaucoup d enfants qu'on voit
dans le reportage on va regarder ce qui
avait été filmée donc par france 2 le 29
avril dernier magnéto serge
une façade apparemment impeccable en
plein xiiie arrondissement de paris 80
personnes habitent ici pour la majorité
des africains la porte d'entrée les
princesses à l'intérieur en fait
l'immeuble tombe en ruine depuis 14 ans
fatouma vite ici avec ses parents et ses
deux frères et soeurs
humidité fille sur l'insalubrité est
telle que les rats ont même élu domicile
dans les appartements
là bas les grosses pierres
les rats circulent de pièce en pièce
puisque les cloisons ne sont pas
étanches un appartement intermédiaire en
attendant un hlm depuis chaque année ils
renouvellent leur demande sans succès et
ça fait 14 ans que ça dure loyer 400
euros par mois dont deux cents de
charges re on est des sauvages ont
vieilli en connecté pour laisser pas ça
du tout quoi c'est pas ça du tout on
cherchait un logement et que la mairie à
s'en fiche complètement de 2,7 de cet
appartement au cinquième étage mêmes
conditions de vie
cette femme attend un logement depuis
neuf ans mais depuis quelques semaines
elle craque son fils de six mois dans
aurait été mordu par un rat en pleine
nuit
mais votez ici après les olé par ici
mais aujourd'hui les habitants craignent
pour leur sécurité et redoute un
incendie de leur côté les architectes
qui ont visité le bâtiment garantissent
qu'il ne s'effondrera pas pour l'instant
voilà fatou vous aviez déclaré à
l'époque si le feu arrive par l'escalier
on sera dans la merde mais c'est ce qui
est arrivé
j'en vois tous mes frères toute ma
famille là tout ce reportage
les gens voient madame cissé avec tous
ses enfants
elle s'est battue jusqu'au bout pour moi
comportement juste un logement
convenable
est parti
c'était la première à se battre à chaque
fois
voilà est plus là
alors
le 26 août ça s'est passé comment vous
vous étiez avec vos parents en fait nous
n'occupe un moment donné mais quand la
famille s'est agrandie les logements ils
étaient trop petits on juge au 5e et
commencé à casser les cloisons pour
comme c'étaient des r3 pour faire des
airs six et abandonner nos unités
c'était pas possible donc nous donner un
autre appartement au 3e alors moi j'ai
pris le troisième avec mes soeurs et ma
fille donc je suis tombée enceinte et et
mon frère il y avait d'autres enfants
qu'ils étaient là haut et ce jour là ça
s'est passé avec ma mère elle était pas
là elle était au mali avec 3 2 de mes
frères et soeurs et on était des en fait
deux séjours c'est au troisième
excusez-moi séjour c'est au troisième et
de l'histoire mais en quoi les chambres
à coucher
et ce genre on était dans le séjour on
discutait matin tu es venait de voir les
enfants là où elle est descendue et
parce que d'habitude ma fille elle
dormait avec moi et mes soeurs qui sont
partis au mali même ce jour-là et une
cousine à moi qui ai vu une voir avec sa
fille on a devait dans ma chambre j'ai
dit à ma fille de monter là-haut et
ma tante elle est descendue on est allé
les voir il dormait pas les 10 ans du et
quand il ouvrait la porte s'est retourné
au troisième il a vu que j'avais un
début d'incendié y avait de la fumée
elle a couru voir mon père en lui disant
qu'il y avait le feu on a tous couru
vers l'escalier pour ouvrir la porte
volontiers et la fumée s'est propagée
il y avait une petite heure de deux ans
qu'on avait on a perdu parce que les
lumières se sont éteintes et c'est la
chercher j'ai pas pu on sait tous ce
réfugié par les fenêtres pour moi j'ai
pas pu aller à la fenêtre si millas
pour respirer un peu d'air et chercher
ma soeur j'ai pas pu la trouver en même
temps et il ya ma cousine tous les jeter
sa fille par la fenêtre mon père lui
disait non non non nous n'avons pas hâte
en jeu j'essaie de l'atelier et lui la
bascule est il tombé en arrière
et pendant ce temps là note et
développeurs elle est tombée et du
témoin il y avait une petite place à la
fenêtre sur les mots je vais le mettre
là bas et au moins il a fait au moins 10
minutes à terre il n'y avait pas les
pompiers avec des policiers et pas les
pompiers quand ils sont arrivés et nous
ont pris son prix le bébé de ma cousine
nous ont fait descendre et je leur ai
dit il y avait ma petite soeur dans la
pièce au troisième ont cherché et n'ont
pas trouvé et je leur criais qu'il y
avait des enfants un cinquième n'y avait
pas d'adulte mais m'écouter pas et
policiers m'ont bousculé voulais pas je
reste là je leur disais il y avait des
enfants il se courait ceux qui hésitent
à la fenêtre seule hantise et les années
pas de fumer chez eux il y avait des
enfants qu'ils étaient tous seuls j'ai
perdu neuf personnes ma famille sept
frères et soeurs ma fille et mon cousin
qui était venue du jour même plus te
voir mon frère il est parti
et ce qui me fait mal c'est que moi
aujourd'hui je suis reparti dans les
meubles pouvoir comment cité l'état dans
la chambre de mes frères il ya vu de lui
tony ceux proposés et un grand il y
avait un placard et août est née la
playstation et tout était en cendres
y'avait rien j'ai vu que de la sambre
par terre mes frères elles ont été
brûlées par terre
et vert
ouais
et aujourd'hui est-ce que vous commencez
je n'en sais rien
je sais pas si je suis encore peur j'ai
encore peur du show
vous prenez des médicaments on se prend
des somnifères pour dormir est-ce que
vous avez un suivi psychologique
j'en avais quand on est au stade mais
début qu'on a déménagé on n'a vu
personne personnes socialement et ça ça
me fait mal on a déménagé depuis
vendredi on est là ça va faire au moins
une semaine il ya personne qui est venu
nous voir une assistante sociale aucune
aide sociale
[Musique]
vous dit j'ai peur de devenir folle oui
j'ai peur
j'ai perdu neuf membres ma fille je vais
même pas dit au revoir quand même monté
juste du voix de coucher d'un euro et 2
mois de décembre du jour au lendemain
j'avais acheté des chaussures pour ma
fait doubler les mêmes gens mais je lui
dise non non non s pour la rentrée la
menace que les sujets je crois que ces
choses je les donne à qui tu tenais à
quitter chose je sais pas pour aller
boire qui parce que
j'en sais rien
fatou si dieu vous a laissé la vie c'est
pour refaire à notre enfant vous croyez
mais je pense comme je suis croyante je
suis musulmane
vous habitez vous aujourd'hui
moi j'invite donc 17e mais là je suis
chez mes parents parce qu'on a perdu
trop de membres de la famille ont passé
paris comme sa photo est ce que c'est
parce que vous êtes noir que vous ne
trouvez pas l'endroit pour vous loger
je dis pas que les blancs sont racistes
je respecte tout le monde mais plus les
noirs sont plus en difficulté que les
personnes blanc et je suis pas raciste
j pas qu'ils sont racistes j'ai pas le
droit de dire parce que il ya certains
ou blanc jeudi blanc excusez moi du
terme mais j'ai des amis qui sont
français espagnols ils ont la couleur
blanche ils sont pas racistes c'est pas
de leur faute mais une loi raison plus
de difficultés à s'intégrer et je sais
pas pourquoi d'avoir des pauses
appartenant à mina pour vous c'est un
problème de racisme
jeu avant de répondre à cette question
permettez moi de présenter d'abord
mettre en liant sa toutes les familles
en deuil parce que cet événement a donné
une dimension
à la communauté africaine vivant en
france et même dans les pays d'origine
puisque le corps des enfants et des
frères et soeurs de fatou sont attendus
partout le mani et on pense en faire des
funérailles nationales parce que tant d
enfants quatorze enfants du coup le mali
n'a jamais connu ça dans de tels drames
vous me parler du racisme je dirais
qu'il ya le racisme parce que moi j'ai
connu la france dans le ton des années
70 qui est complètement différente de la
france d'aujourd'hui la france des
années soixante dix mois quand je suis
arrivé adolescente que j'étais j'avais
l'âge de 13 ans j'ai fait le collège en
france entouré adoré par des français de
souche j'ai fait le lycée entouré adoré
par des français de souche j'ai fait la
fac enterré et adoré par des français de
souche mais la france d'aujourd'hui je
me retrouve pas du tout je me retrouve
pas tant elle est devenue austère temps
elle est devenue méconnaissable
pour des raisons que je ne m'explique
pas ce que j'ai vécu toutes les crises
économiques en france j'ai vécu la
transformation de la société française
je vais tout simplement un message à
passer être pauvre n'est pas une tare la
pauvreté est universel tout dépend de la
façon dont elle est partagée et dont la
solidarité s'organise autour de cette
pauvreté l'afrique est pauvre de
l'afrique et mme ding ding pourquoi
quand il ya eu cet événement rallys
tisme grave nous avons reçu des
instructions de la des autorités
maliennes de rester digne et de pallier
justement au drame de ces familles là de
les entourer et le gouvernement malien a
envoyé quatre ministres de vendredi à
samedi quatre ministres sont venus dont
un délégué spécialement qui s'appelle
monsieur des cookies et le ministre des
maliens de l'extérieur
l'afrique a changé l'afrique évolue
parce que deux en même temps que nous
sommes en train de faire cette émission
vous être regardée par des millions de
maliens en direct ça il faut que les
gens le sachent l'internet et puis les
médias actuels sont partout des
africains le verbe de partout donc c'est
moi c'est ce que j'ai dit il ya le
racisme il faut que les français se
ressaisissent qui se disent que ces
africains qui sont là qui sont
différents apporte aussi si vous voulez
un changement apporte de la richesse
parce que moi ce que j'ai appris c'est
mes ancêtres les gaulois et quand je
suis là aujourd'hui c'est pour
m'exprimer en amitié et comme je partage
avec fatoumata quand elle dit que les
français ne sont pas racistes il faut
faire la part des choses tous les
français ne sont pas racistes il ya des
français qui sont ouverts mais il faut
construire et saisissent tout ce qu'on
se dise qu'on partage un patrimoine
commun qui s'appelle la culture
française si ce que je peux vous dire en
opérationnel
je viens
mais les africains de france on colore
là
je pense que les africains l'ailé les
français eux mêmes doivent être en
colère pour la plupart
moi aussi je suis très en colère oui on
peut qu'être en colère quand on a dû
tout ça et il est vrai que quand j'ai
rencontré amina elle avait un discours
qui me plaisait parce que elle me disait
que la responsabilité venait de tout le
monde venait de la france comme de
l'afrique fall venait de tout le monde
et je trouve que c'est juste c'est juste
de s'exprimer sur sur les 2 et de france
je suis désolé parce que j'ai écouté les
des matches nuls témoignage de fatou et
j'ai été renversé et on peut être que je
respecte et on étudie à rien la colère
est la honte on a été avec stomy voir
voir toutes ces familles on a écouté
toutes ces familles et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on se devait de venir
dire ce qu'on a vu quoi c'est c'est pas
possible je sais pas ce que tu en penses
quoi sony mais ce tome i
j'ai juste une déclaration à faire j'ai
tapé quelque chose pour les droites au
but cela n'engage que moi
alors vas-y dans un pays comme la france
des familles nombreuses et vivent
entassés dans des pièces insalubre
minuscule avec des cafards des rats et
des souris certaines de ces familles
sont sur liste d'attenté pour un
appartement depuis environ 15 ans en
attendant chaque instant représente un
risque de court-circuit d'inondations
d'effondrements de murs et j'en passe
ces familles vivent en permanence dans
le danger et la grande majorité est
d'origine d'afrique noire comme vous le
savez il avait vu je ne vous apprends
rien au cours de ces six derniers mois
une cinquantaine de personnes sont
mortes brûlés ou intoxiqués par les
flammes les trois incendies dont 36
enfants sans compter une dizaine de
blessés graves et des familles rescapés
complètement traumatisée deux heures
après le drame du boulevard vincent
auriol monsieur sarkozy se pointe comme
une fleur et on se demandait une
rescapée de l'immeuble si les victimes
étaient en situation régulière
moins d'une semaine après la catastrophe
plutôt que de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
restaurer ces taudis prologis tout le
monde les forces de l'ordre n'ont rien
trouvé de mieux à faire que d'expulser
les familles des deux bâtiments sans
proposer de l'hérault logé à 6 ils ont
proposé de les parquer dans de
minuscules chambres d'hôtel proches
périphérique ils ne sont toujours pas
sortis de l'auberge et tout ça le jour
de la rentrée des classes
est ce cela l'état d'esprit de tout le
peuple français
si c'est comme ça que le gouvernement
règle ses problèmes qu'ils ne s'étonnent
pas de savoir cracher à la face dans les
quartiers sensibles je vous rappelle que
ces gens sont venus ici en france terre
d'accueil pour travailler honnêtement et
durement je vous rappelle aussi que ces
familles payent des loyers des impôts et
que la plupart sont en situation
régulière
et même si elle ne l'était pas en ces
temps de catastrophe naturelle un homme
reste un homme avec ou sans papiers
aucun d'eux ne méritent qu'on les traite
aujourd'hui comme des chiens des
sous-hommes ou des citoyens de seconde
zone aucune mère ne mérite d'être séparé
de ses enfants
comme aucun père ne méritent les coups
de matraque devant sa famille pour les
déloger j accuse les propriétaires les
agences immobilières ne pas vouloir
louer leurs appartements aux africains
et aux immigrés en général
j'accuse l'état de fermer les yeux sur
ces réalités mais quoi qu'il en soit
même les yeux bandés et les aurait
bouché rien ne pourra vous empêcher de
respirer l'odeur des corps calcinés car
leur amour au post en paix
des marches silencieuses ont été suivies
en mémoire de toutes ces victimes c'est
bien mais aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
c'est faire du bruit réclamer des
dédommagements pour les familles des
victimes demandent et la construction de
plus de logements sociaux demandé
l'interdiction des expulsions sans
relogement et demander la réquisition et
la réhabilitation de tous les logements
vides et croyez-moi yona avec tout ce
que la france a pris à l'afrique en
sommes en richesse en sang elle pourrait
au moins être juste et laisser aux
enfants de ceux morts pour la mère
patrie la possibilité de vivid habité
autre chose que des taudis unissons-nous
dans un esprit de liberté de fraternité
et d'équité
voilà
maintenant chacun à faire ce qui peut
j'espère en tous les cas que tout le
monde a pris conscience du problème
merci merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux